from repelling down mountains to
ascending the throne it's a busy time
for the royal family we know that Prince
William is going to have a pretty high
profile and significant role not just in
the ceremony itself but the leader to
the coronation along with the Princess
of Wales the head of King Charles's
coronation his son Prince William is
keeping busy with a little work and play
alongside wife Kate Middleton that's
Kate and William meeting up with a
mountain rescue team in Wales to take
part in some training activities and
William he gets a little competitive
the bottom
well the prince and princess prove they
both got skills
the bear also taking part in medical
support exercises and a search dog
rescue demo a couple clearly big fans of
the hard-working pups
they've got lovely temperatures and
after the hard day of work Kate and
Williams show their thanks to the team
with the pizza party
I think where Kate has been so clever is
to create her own prototype of the
Princess of Wales through the work that
she and William do putting the spotlight
on on those who don't have a voice I
think now we are seeing the seeds that
have been sewn we are seeing the work
that she's put 10 years into now coming
to fruition and it's work that really is
making a difference the royal families
all keeping busy with their trips across
the UK ahead of the May 6 ceremony King
Charles and queen Camilla visited
Liverpool Tuesday it was always the
king's intent to hit the ground running
and I think we've absolutely seen him do
that he's traveled tirelessly around the
country he's preparing for a series of
Tours both before his coronation on May
the 6th and after that coronation so he
is really sort of putting down the
markers of his new reign
the coronation marks Charles's transfer
of his titles and Powers following the
death of his mother Queen Elizabeth it's
set to be a big celebration including a
concert with A-list singers performing
including American Idol judges Lionel
Richie and Katy Perry what is it like
for you
um I'm just
American Idol when I tell you that I
mean it's just it's correct I can tell
you there's more secrecy than you've
ever could imagine in your life we can
expect to see heads of state presidents
Prime Ministers past and present members
of foreign royal families and and other
VIPs but closer to 2000 in number not
the 8 000 that we saw for the Queen's
coronation a huge amount of planning has
to go into an important moment in
history such as a coronation
[Music]
foreign